علامتني هذه الطائره وصل وفد الاثيوبيا
ضخم الى الخرطوم يقوده رئيس الوزراء باحمد
الرجل الذي جاء مبتسما وحاملا عددا من
الملفات في حقيبته قضى يوما طويلا مليئا
بلقاءات والمباحثات شحيحا في المقترحات
صافره البدايه كانت مع رئيس مجلس السياده
الذي اكد اتفاقهم على كافه القضايا
المتعلقه بسد النهضه وان يحتكم الطرفان
الى الوثائق فيما يتعلق بموضوع الحدود
مكتتما حديثه بثناء موهود على علاقات
البلدين
من امورنا وهي كلها نريدها ان تصب في
مصلحه الشعبين لتقويه هذه العلاقه بين
الدولتين الجارتين الشقيقتين
بعيدا عن الخلافات الخارجيه قريبا الى
المشاكل الداخليه لقاءات المطوله اجراها
ابي احمد مع الكتل والقوه السياسيه بمختلف
اتجاهاتها لقاءات تستهدف الاستماع اكثر من
تقديم حلول جديده
الطريقه التي تمت بها
تشكيل الوضع الانتقالي
وتحويل هذا الوضع الى صراع الى صراع
للاحزاب على السلطه الانتقاليه
توافق بين الاطراف السودانيه مع مساء
تقودها القاهره بين القوى السياسيه والتي
من المقرر ان يغادر معظمها الى مصر نهايه
الشهر الجاري يبدو واضحا ان مسعى كل دوله
يسير في اتجاه مختلف
شكل من اشكال التنافس المصري الاثيوبي على
الاراضي السودانيه ومحاوله كل طرف من
الاطراف بان تكون له اليد الطول في حل
الازمه السودانيه
ابي احمد استمرت ساعات فهل تستتكمل
اللقاءات التي جرت في الخرطوف اديس ابابا
لاحداث توافق القريب ام انها ستنتقل الى
القاهره لاحداث اختراق جديد لن يعقوب
العربيه الخرطوم